was it the holidays no it wasn't that
well then why you decided to come in
tonight um trying to fix my mind Howard
is a brilliant man he's not just a boss
he's a friend
he lost his child and now he doesn't
care if he loses everything else this
might be the strangest thing I have ever
come across
he writes letters who are they - Howard
doesn't write letters to people he
writes two things time love death kids
write letters a Santa Claus it doesn't
mean they're crazy no this is
therapeutic you don't think I'm crazy
but I'm having conversations death came
first she met me in the dog park charmed
I'm sure
so death is or her turns out death is an
elderly white woman remember me I'm time
you wrote me because you need Howard
asked what asked her she can see me he
was sitting right here and he just
appeared right
I'm loved and I'm with fabric of life
something's trying to happen to you
Howard
I don't know what to do to bring you
back
what if love death and time for trying
to help you you need to talk to them
Howard challenged them just in games
the reason for everything I felt you
every day when she laughed and you broke
my heart I was there in her love but I'm
also here now in your pain
he's reaching out to the cosmos for
answers
just be sure to notice the collateral
beauty
it's the profound connection to
everything except that maybe he gets to
find his life again
[Music]
not here to take me are you know Howard
I'm here to write the F train with you
that's love tonight we're here to
connect love time death now these three
things connect every single human being
on earth we long for love you wish we
had more time and we fear death
did you lose a child Howard Howard is a
brilliant creative charismatic guy used
to love life right now he hates it I
tried to talk to him I tried to reach
him and he's not there I miss him he
writes letters who are they - Howard
doesn't write letters to people he
writes to things time love death kids
write letters a Santa Claus it doesn't
mean they're crazy no this is
therapeutic
who did you write the letter to I wrote
a letter to death
nice to meet you there charmed I'm sure
no people write letters to the universe
all the time most don't get a personal
response that you are I don't want this
I'm time I'm a gift and you're wasting
it you don't think I'm crazy but I'm
having conversations I am loved
don't try and live without me Howard I
saw you in her eyes when she called me
daddy and you betrayed me I'm the reason
for everything if you can accept that
then maybe you get sniff again
[Music]
he's reaching out to the cosmos for
pants's
there's so much more at stake here than
you even understand
you've been given a gift his profound
connection to everything just look for
it
I promise you it's there
the collateral beauty
[Music]
you